[Musica]
Buon pomeriggio
Eccoci qua
questa la mettiamo qui l'oggetto del
desiderio Avete appena visto il mio
primo di 100 satelliti non sono qui però
per parlare di scienza bensì di Come
arrivare a creare un qualcosa del genere
Qualunque cosa sia
Beh per me questo viaggio è stato
veramente importante abbiamo
creato veramente tantissime cose per
arrivare a creare un satellite ne
abbiamo distrutti veramente tanti
abbiamo bruciato veramente tanti
prototipi abbiamo creato tante
aspettative
e poi abbiamo avuto anche tantissimi No
tantissimi vi racconto un po' la storia
abbiamo iniziato con un'idea volevamo
interconnettere il mondo in maniera
diversa in quelle cose un po' piccole ok
bene
Allora che cosa abbiamo detto Beh noi
sappiamo qualcosa di antenne Ok però
dobbiamo creare un'antenna e dobbiamo
metterla in alto e allora abbiamo detto
va bene facciamo un satellite Questa è
la storia
Ma andiamo un po' più nel dettaglio
abbiamo chiesto dei fondi agli enti
spaziali per aiutarci
Beh abbiamo scritto dei pacchi così di
documentazione abbiamo fatto i nostri
brevetti la strada maestra bene non ci
hanno mai risposto mai non ci hanno mai
risposto ma
abbiamo fatto una scommessa con noi
stessi abbiamo detto
lanciamoci investiamo tutto quello che
abbiamo tutto tutto
tutti ingegneri tutti i ricercatori
partiamo lanciamoci proviamo
bene e questo è stato il risultato
siamo riusciti
andare un po' contro quello che è la
strada maestra
arrivando ad un obiettivo che oggi è la
prima missione completamente privata
italiana
e questo è un brevetto completamente
italiano
e questo è Grazie sicuramente al lavoro
di squadra perché in Italia Abbiamo
bisogno di ripartire un pochettino da
dal gruppo dal senso del gruppo perché
il One Man Show No la persona singola
diciamo che lascia un po' il tempo che
trova perché da soli non si va da
nessuna parte inizialmente all'inizio di
questo viaggio ero da solo
tante idee
tanti progetti tanto studio ma non
bastava non bastava e piano piano la
vita me l'ha insegnato ho iniziato molto
presto bruciato qualche tappa va bene
però
quando ti dai un obiettivo alto andare
da solo non è molto bello non è molto
appagante invece trovare dei compagni di
viaggio è molto molto importante
Ho imparato tantissimo ho trovato
persone
meravigliosamente belle e molte anche
brutte abbiamo perso diversi prototipi
abbiamo lanciato
dei soldi in aria per dirla così
Ma poi le prime cose hanno iniziato a
funzionare siamo riusciti a
rimpicciolire una tecnologia che
inizialmente si pensava dovesse costare
milioni e milioni di euro
e inizialmente la società valeva
pochissimo Bene Iniziamo con i primi
test non demordiamo andiamo tutti
insieme superando tutte le fasi iniziali
quindi dall'idea al prototipo un po'
brutto da vedere
e poi piano piano rimpiccioliamo
riusciamo a creare un oggetto talmente
tanto piccolo da abbattere i costi in
maniera esponenziale
bene
arrivati fin qui nessuno ci ha detto a
Complimenti dai Andate avanti no è
dovuto partire tutto da noi stessi e
inventi
è un po' complicato ci siamo detti
qualunque cosa qualunque
però poi alla fine piano piano siamo
riusciti a creare questo
questo
Questo è il satellite in scala 1 che
avete visto prima
[Applauso]
questo ci dà una mano da tantissimi
punti di vista
tutta la parte di agricoltura
intelligente di precisione
adesso è servita la parte di
telemedicina possiamo monitorare i
nostri parametri vitali e possiamo anche
non farceli fregare Ecco questo è nato
per questo e in più riusciamo anche ad
avere tutti i ponti potenzialmente le
nostre infrastrutture
monitorate in maniera tale che non
succedano i disastri che
abbiamo visto
questa soluzione ha uno scopo alto ho
iniziato da solo ed è stato un errore
gravissimo
Di solito noi tutti partiamo con un'idea
partiamo con noi stessi
ma intraprendiamo un viaggio tutti
assieme e incontriamo persone e non
dobbiamo avere paura Oggi ne ho un po'
perché siete tanti
Però anche questo fa parte del viaggio
e oggi sono qui
proprio per dire questo non dobbiamo
avere paura soprattutto ognuno di noi
per la ricerca che vogliamo fare per il
satellite che volete fare naturalmente
qualunque progetto Se ci mettete il
vostro e trovate i vostri compagni di
viaggio riuscirete sicuramente a
traguardare tutti i vostri successi
anche quando attraverserete la fase dei
No perché la fase dei no ci sarà sempre
io ne ho lanciato uno e Devo lanciare
altri 100 quindi la strada è ancora
lunga parecchio però intanto il primo
passo l'abbiamo fatto e abbiamo anche
convinto quelli che ci hanno detto di no
inizialmente quindi questa è una chiave
di lettura importante
lanciarsi Prima no fregandosene anche un
pochettino
vi lascio con una frase
il successo non si misura da quanto in
alto vai ma da quante persone Riesci a
portarti con te
Grazie